جريمه بدم بارد ذهب ضحيتها المبتعث
السعودي الوليد الغريبي كان في الخامسه
والعشرين من العمر حين طلته يد الغدر
امريكيه في 19 من العمر مسرح الجريمه هذا
المنزل في فلادلفيا شرطه المدينه
بعد ان القت القبض عليها من دون ان تذكر
الشرطه سبب تعني روجرز للمبتعه في
السعوديه او ما اذا كانت تعرف الضحيه
صاحبه المبنى الذي كان يسكنه المبتعث
السعودي المقتول الوليد الغريبي روى
التفاصيل الحادثه للعربيه مؤكده ان
الوليده كان شخصا خلوقا ورائعا صاحبه
المبنى رواه انها تلقت اتصال من سكان
المنزل الاخرين بعد سماعهم اصواتا مخنوقه
بالقرب منهم وعندما وصلت صاحبه المنزل
وجدت نيكول ماريتو ينظ الارض بطريقه غريبه
فوقاشجار قوي بينهما ولكن سرعان ما هربت
القاتل من المنزل بعد ان ركبت سيارتها
بسرعه في هذه الاثناء اتجهت صاحبه المنزل
لاستكشاف ما يحدث في الداخل لتكتشف ان
بابا دوله المياه كان مقفلا فحاولت خلعه
بقوه للدخول اليه لتجد الوليد بعدها غارقا
بدمائه وهو يلفظ انفاسه الاخيره هنا هرعت
السيده للاتصال بالشرطه التي وصلت بعد عشر
دقائق لتعلن وفاه الوليد المطعون بالرقبه
في تمام الساعه
11:50 دقيقه صباحا
محاسن حضاره العربيه